programs usually seen at this time will
not be shown tonight in order to bring
you this special program now a special
program in living color on NBC
the 43rd annual academy award show
here's the poem the Los Angeles Music
Center fans have been waiting since
early this morning to catch a glimpse of
the stars as they arrive for the awards
ceremony at Ryan O'Neal
they were young George Segal versatile
young actor
as former Oscar winner Jenner
Jones has an Oscar in the Best Actress
category in general at the army over and
Bradley with his wife kitty there's Lee
grant nominee for Best Supporting
Actress the maximilian schell nominated
this producer in the foreign film
the esteemed multi talented actress
ginger odd
there's Jack Nicholson also a nominee
for love story in Ali MacGraw gorgeous
Ali nominated for best actress escorted
by her husband Robert evidence paramount
studio head
tonight the Academy Awards Orchestra
will be conducted by three-time Oscar
nominee Quincy Jones
ladies and gentlemen the president of
the Academy of Motion Picture Arts and
Sciences and a former Academy Award
winner himself mr. Daniel taradash
good evening in the 19 years the awards
have been telecast there has never been
a commercial about the Academy
I can't withstand the temptation what is
the Academy who are we well it takes a
lot of people to make a motion picture
and our 3,600 members include almost all
of those who make most of the best what
does the Academy do many things we
maintain the Margaret Herrick library
undoubtedly the world's finest
collection of material relating to film
it's open to the public it's used to a
fare-thee-well we carry on a rainbow of
other activities in the last three years
for example we've given a young lady
funds to write a book on the popular
image of women as portrayed in American
films and to another to help her finish
a movie on the contemporary life of the
crow Indians and to to teachers to
prepare a textbook on how they used
motion pictures to improve dramatically
the reading ability of pupils in
inner-city high schools we endowed a
chair at the American Film Institute
made a grant to the National Film Board
of Canada and another to the United
Nations as part of the budget of a
documentary to be made in Africa by a
brilliant young filmmaker from Gambia we
gave a scholarship in music composition
for the screen allotted funds for cinema
students to intern on the set with
eminent directors published with the
Writers Guild a monumental reference
book called who wrote the movie we've
given grants to students to write
screenplays and to others to make films
and to others to complete films and we
made a grant to one very promising
student who took it and immediately
disappeared and oh yes once a year we
give academy awards which brings me I
admit by a circuitous route to tonight
perhaps you've wondered in the past how
we're able to show the winners instantly
after they're announced and how the
orchestra just as instantly begins the
theme music of that particular music
well here we are at rehearsal yesterday
is able to move in on the winner so
quickly because he's assigned seats for
every nominee for every award photos are
used to help the cameraman memorize
where the stars will be seated as the
stand-in opens the envelope and the
winner is Cromwell of course at this
point the real envelopes are locked in a
safe at the accounting firm of Price
Waterhouse so we play out a charade with
fake announcements
this is done with all the possible
winners in order for Quincy Jones and
his orchestra to rehearse their cues
with appropriate music as soon as the
winner is announced Quincy is ready with
the downbeat and the musicians are ready
to go into the correct theme and the
winner is the Hawaiians
and and now and now that you know how
it's done let's do it
I'm happy to present some of Oscars best
friends first Sally Kellerman
Jim Brown
Angie Dickinson and park back line
young blonde down
John Marley
oh yeah pooja
New York stable
all of Brandis
early go
Walter Matthau
you'll be on the crowd
Glen Campbell
Earl Oberon
Don Paolo
Ryan O'Neal
IVA police say
only on
Belle Epoque
to comply with the FCC regulations we
have to tell you this year as usual all
eligible Academy members voted for
nominations for the best picture of the
year the other nominations were made by
members of the Academy branches
specialists in their fields
finally Academy members voted for all
the awards of Merit the secret ballots
were tabulated by the accounting firm of
Price Waterhouse we got all that okay
now here to break the first seal Shirley
Jones and John Marley
John I really want to congratulate you
on your nomination for love story well
thank you Shirley
I've watched this show before I know
what happens to the winners but tell me
what happens to the losers well after
the show they meet in the parking lot
and read their acceptance speeches to
each other right the parking lot a well
I'll remember that just in case now the
nominees for best achievement in sound
are Ronald Pierce and David Moriarty for
airport Douglas Williams and Don bossman
for Patton Gordon Kay McCallum and John
Brahmo for Ryan's daughter Marie Spivak
and Herman Lewis for Torah Torah Torah
Don Wallen and Larry Johnson for
Woodstock the winner is the winners are
Douglas Williams and Don Bassman for
Pappy
thank you I thank you and I'm very
grateful and humble for this great honor
I want to thank everyone who had
anything to do with the picture of
Patton and the management at Fox Studios
for their confidence and faith in me I
wish to thank George C Scott for a fine
performance as General Patton
our wonderful producer Frank McCarthy a
very talented director Franklin
Schaffner our two sound directors James
Corcoran and John Bonner and also my
very talented associates on the picture
Murray Spivak and Ted Soderbergh and our
inspired sound effects editors Don Hall
dick Jensen bill Hartmann and Don Isaacs
thank you again I'd like to take a
moment to thank you gentlemen that I
took to Europe with me who perform so
admirably and really are a part of this
I think they're the best in the business
my boom man Victor good and my recorder
Don Parker million thanks to Frank
McCarthy and also to Franklin Schaffner
and they were both just marvelous thank
you very much